the reality is the projects have to work
financially if they don't either that
one will be a disaster or you won't be
able to do the next one Harbor Point is
a new 1 billion dollar masterplan
mixed-use community that will support
thousands of construction jobs as well
as permanent jobs and generate on
average nearly 20 million dollars in new
city tax revenue annually 20 years in
the making Harbor Point looks to be one
of the biggest developments in
Baltimore's history on this site of a
former chromium factory will house two
of America's largest corporations Morgan
Stanley and exelon corporation the whole
development will benefit from four
hundred million dollars in taxpayer
subsidy it's all a part of a deal known
as tax increment financing or TIF in
which the developer will be exempt from
taxation for a decade keenly aware of
the city's history of development some
citizens have taken to the streets and
I'm here because I'm against the Harbor
Point tip because it's a bad deal I know
this because failed development has been
Warner for a long time
well the rich people are living in
public house you know they don't call it
welfare they call it subsidies but they
live at the Harbor and all of that
property is subsidized by the public by
the taxpayer at Harbor Point when people
ask the question when is the time that
subsidies end what what is there the
reality is that the TIF is going into
infrastructure we still need to
privately financed the buildings and I
will tell you it's not easy a year
before accepting tax breaks for his
Harbor Point development BTW described
how baltimore should be pursuing
development no subsidies no breaks an
equal playing field for everybody but
have the tax rate be similar to what it
is in the surrounding counties to
understand why even the developer would
oppose tax subsidies look closer at the
Harbor Point site at first glance the
27-acre Peninsula appears to be prime
real estate but no one will touch the
site of a toxic chromium factory in the
middle of a city with one of the highest
property tax rates in the nation that's
why Baltimore businesses either lobby
for special favors or they give
themselves a tax break by moving out of
town across the county line it's a
policy that's left the city looking
pretty empty these days dominated by a
handful of large politically connected
tax-exempt institutions like johns
hopkins university and the catholic
church why is the city giving hundreds
of millions of dollars old tech
sweeteners to a private developer my
answer to that is the city historically
has always been in the development
business so this is where it all began
Baltimore's love affair with large-scale
development and from this angle
Baltimore looks like the picture of a
prosperous city but if you look at the
history of the inner harbor it tells a
very different story
welcome to baltimore home to scenic
inner harbor wracked by race riots white
flight and chronic mismanagement what's
a blighted post-industrial city to do
why remake itself as a glittering
tourist pleasure garden naturally
Baltimore's politicians spent 30 years
and nearly 2 billion dollars to sweep
away its rotting factories and crumbling
piers of years past replacing them with
hotels a world-class aquarium and unique
restaurants that can only be found in
742 other metropolitan areas Architects
hailed the transformation is one of the
supreme achievements of large-scale
urban development in American history
and tourists flowed into Baltimore by
the tens of millions but more residents
and businesses than ever before moved in
the opposite direction they left behind
a city that the tourists didn't see one
with rising crime a declining public
school system and a government that
seemed more focused on corralling
day-trippers and meeting the needs of
the people who called the city home
come see Baltimore
City Council gave final approval for
that controversial new Harbor Point
development late this afternoon and what
was it times a contentious hearing this
is a great project for the citizens of
Baltimore Harbor Point means a fresh
start for a long lighted and vacant site
along our city's waterfront today it
seems the city hasn't been able to find
a way in which if a development becomes
successful the city would get its money
back I'm not optimistic about what the
mayor and the City Council are doing
because in the end it has to be the
private market that is going to do the
things having overcome every political
obstacle in its way Harbor Point is
currently on hold pending environmental
review of carcinogenic chromium on the
site a sharp reminder of Baltimore's
industrial past despite the setbacks the
project could still be a massive
turnaround that restores not only the
local economy but the reputation of city
authorities or it could end up is
another painful episode in the city's
long history of urban renewal failures
it may take a decade before construction
is complete and the public as an answer